now going to talk about one of the
greatest philosophers and teachers in
human history and that is Confucius
known to the Chinese as Cong C which
means master Kong or Kong food C which
means Grandmaster Kong and once again my
apologies for my pronunciation the word
Confucius is a Latinization
of Kong food see so you could imagine
Confucius Confucius now what's
interesting about Confucius is he grew
up in a time when China was getting more
and more divided in other videos we
talked about the Jo dynasty which begins
at the very end of the second millennium
but in the time of Confucius we're in
what's known as the end of the spring
and autumn period Confucius lid from 551
to 479 BCE and we're ending the spring
and autumn period and we're getting into
the period of the warring States so even
in the time of Confucius there was more
and more tension between States people
felt less confident in the central
government and as we'll see in this late
spring and autumn period and especially
as we get into this really violent
period known as the warring States
Period a lot of philosophers started to
arise and philosophies began to rise
because people were struggling with
these questions of what is the role of
the state what it what does it mean to
be a good person how does humanity fit
in with the cosmic order now what's
interesting about Confucius is by his
own account he he says that he didn't
come up with anything new it's more of
him trying to resuscitate or rejuvenate
some of the traditions of the past most
historians would give him more credit
even though Confucius does look to the
early Jo dynasty for a lot of his
inspiration and he looks to a lot of the
traditions of the ancestors he
definitely puts a spin on it
which makes it a very powerful
philosophy and arguable arguably
religion as we get into this warring
States Period and especially as we get
into a more unified China on
the Qin and Han dynasties and as we'll
see under the Han Dynasty in particular
Confucianism
becomes essentially the state religion
now to get a sense of what Confucius
preached and his life he spent most of
his life both teaching and preaching a
lot of people compare him to Socrates
even though he predates Socrates and
simultaneously he was also building a
career as a civil servant but his legacy
is definitely around his preachings and
most of his life was here in the state
of Lu in eastern China so there's three
general themes that you could you could
talk about Confucius's teachings you I
encourage you to go look at his Analects
they're quite interesting to get many
many more of them but a lot of it are at
is around respecting traditions and
respecting elders here's a quote from
the Analects a young man should serve
his parents at home and be respectful to
elder's outside his home he should be
earnest and truthful loving all but
becoming intimate with his innate good
heart heartedness after doing this if he
has interview despair he can study
literature in the arts and there's a lot
of talk of if someone is to be a good
citizen they need to be a good a good
child first they need to be a good son
now he also talks about what does it
mean to be a just ruler if you control
people by punishment they will avoid
crime but have no personal sense of
shame if you govern them by means of
virtue and control them with propriety
they will gain their own sense of shame
and thus correct themselves and as we'll
see morality and ethics plays a huge
role at a personal level and also as a
state level to Confucius and we'll talk
about other philosophies where that
might not be as strong of a sense now
another very big theme to Confucius was
looking to yourself through
self-improvement you can be a better
citizen a better child a better ruler
real knowledge is to know the extent of
one's ignorant learning without thought
is labor lost thought without learning
is perilous when you see someone of
worth think of how you
they emulate when you see someone
unworthy examine your own character I
like that one in particular do not
impose on others what you yourself do
not desire so a very close statement to
the golden rule now as I mentioned
Confucius and Confucianism was not alone
in this in this period of the Spring and
Autumn Period and especially as you get
into the warring States Period during
that time we have what's known as the
hundred schools of thought which that
this time period starts around the time
of Confucius and goes until Qin Dynasty
ends the warring States Period in a very
strong way unifies China now we already
talked about Confucianism which talks a
lot about ethics but it its goal
remember Confucius himself was a civil
servant he was an administrator he
thought a lot about what does it mean to
be a just ruler so it definitely touches
on the practical to a good bit now many
people say it's a pickle system but many
would also consider it a religion
because it does touch on the medical
physical the notions of heaven and it
borrows a lot from China's past now
other samples of the hundred schools of
thought especially ones that had a
significant role on China's history and
even modern China include the legalists
the legalists have a strong pragmatism
they are dismissive of the Confucian
notion of strong internal ethics and
that will guide people and rulers
legalists are much more about look we
need a strong orderly central state we
need to do whatever it takes and it
might be clamping down on people hard in
order to bring in order to to have a
have stability in order to have rule and
you can imagine the context in which the
legalism is coming about this is during
the warring States Period this
incredibly violent period where the
states in China are fragmented and so
you could imagine these people who are
very realistic they're like look we've
had this Confucianism we have these
other philosophies but we we need strong
super centralized rulers
and it ends up being that legalist
philosophy that wins the day as you have
the emergence of the Qin Dynasty in 221
and the Qin Dynasty is what modern China
is named after and it's considered the
first dynasty to really unify China in a
very strong way and create its
administrative and bureaucratic systems
it really is based on legalism and it
was able to put an end to this warring
States Period by putting so much power
central power and strong rulers who are
willing to be quite violent in
repressing other people in order to
bring that stability and notable that
the the emergence of the Qin is also
considered the end of the hundred
schools of thought because the Qin as
part of that order started persecuting
many of the other forms of philosophy
including many of those that followed
confucius now other forms of philosophy
and this is just a sample that have
strongly influenced China you have
Taoism Taoism is according to Taoist
belief comes comes from Lao Zi and the
historical record of Lao Zi isn't as
clear as we have for Confucius but it's
believed that he lived around the same
time some people view him as more of a
legendary figure but Taoism is much more
concerned with the spiritual than
Confucianism you see quotes the Dao is
really the way it's all about harmony
with the universe free from desire you
realize the mystery caught in desire you
see only the manifestations the diode a
Ching now later on Buddhism it's
interesting Buddha is lived at around
the same time once again his birth and
date under a little bit more contention
as Confucius and he lives in northeast
India Nepal area and Buddhism really
comes about in India but it eventually
makes its way into China as especially
as we get into the first millennium CE
II and in modern-day China a lot of the
culture in the philosophy in the
religion is a combination in particular
of Confucianism most strongly but also
Taoism and Buddhism but there are other
philosophies for example mo ism
a quite interesting one I encourage you
to look at it but it's all about this
notion of impartial love it actually has
a lot of similarities parallels with the
teachings of Jesus as told by the
Gospels but that notion was viewed
somewhat impractical by many of the
followers of Confucius and especially
the legalists and Moe ISM really didn't
last much beyond the Qin Dynasty but one
way to think about it is legalism
allowed the Qin Dynasty to really end
the warring States period and centralize
China but then that short-lived dynasty
as they transition to the Han the Han
took over the the administrative
structure and the stability of the Qin
to a large degree but then they made
Confucianism really the state philosophy
and you could even say the state
religion and to appreciate the
importance of Confucianism to Chinese
culture I'll leave you with this last
quote by the historian hustin smith for
though Confucius did not author Tiny's
culture as we talked about even
Confucius says I didn't invent anything
he was its supreme editor